اذا المارد ذكي خرج من القمقم ولا يمكن
اعادته مجددا وهنا الاعتماد على صاحب
الامنيه او الطلب فمارد الذكاء الاصطناعي
يزداد قدره وخطوره يوميا وتزداد معه
المخاوف من تهديد البشريه او حتى القضاء
عليها مجموعه من خبراء التقنيات
والكمبيوتر العالميين طالبوا في بيان
العمل على جعل مخاطر ذكاء الصناعي اولويه
مثله مثل الجائحات والحرب النوويه
وللمفارقه شملت قائمه الموقعين سام التمان
وهو رئيس شركه اوبني اي صاحب موديل الذكاء
الصناعي الاشهر تشاد
هو عالم الكمبيوتر المعروف بلقب الاب
الروحي لذكاء الصناعي الخطر على البشريه
استخلص من قدره انظمه ذكاء الاصطناعي على
تعلم سلوك غير متوقع من كميه البيانات
الهائله التي تحللها ثم التحرر من قيودها
وفق نيويورك تايمز
الاخر يتمثل بالمعلومات المضلله وحتى
تخريب فمن الممكن جعله يوفر معلومات غير
صحيحه في حاله تم استدراجه او طرح السؤال
عليه بطريقه معدل توجيه الجواب في اتجاه
معين من مخاطره ايضا الثقه المفرطه اي
الاعتماد على البيانات الاحصائيه في نظام
العداله وتقديم رعايه طبيه اي اتخاذ
قرارات مصيريه بدلا من البشر وفيما يبقى
الخوف الاكبر من استيلاء انظمه الذكاء
الاصطناعي على الوظائف اكدت مجله انها
ستشكل فرصا واعده لتحسين الحياه ولن ترتكب
الاخطاء في حال برمجتها بشكل صحيح
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات